DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don's Dodge, and this is
"Google Root Access," the show
for startups.
And today we're going to talk
about user design and user
experience.
I have a special guest, Izabel
Idris, who focuses on mobile
applications and user
experience.
Izabel has worked with several
large companies to develop
applications and has also
had her own startup.
So, welcome Izabel.
IZABEL IDRIS: Thank you.
DON DODGE: So we're going to
talk about how to start
building an app that delivers
a great user experience.
So let's say I have a great
idea for a startup and--
how do I create user
experience?
What does that mean?
IZABEL IDRIS: I think the way
to get started is to really,
as a company or as a team,
define your goals, define your
user, and from that you create
personas and use cases.
So personas are a fictional user
that actually capture all
the attributes of the real users
that your application is
tailored for.
So what you really want to do is
actually think of features
and implementation last.
You really want to understand
your goals, your use cases,
and personas, and throughout
the implementation process,
you want to always kind of
go back to those, kind of
reference that, because as
startups, you're pivoting
frequently, stress can get high,
you run out of time, you
have limited resources.
So you always want to know
really, why are we here?
What are our goals?
What is the most basic thing?
What do we really
need to nail?
You got a nail the right things,
get things right.
You need to get the right
things right.
And so I think that it's really
important to always
kind of reference those
throughout the process.
DON DODGE: So when you talk
about personas and use cases,
I think what you're saying is
that for the same application
there could be different users
and different use cases.
Is that what you're
getting at?
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
An application can have several
different personas,
and for each one of those
personas, you have several
different use cases.
There's a whole process about
how to create use cases and
personas, but basically you
always want to make sure that
your application, your
experiences and service of
those personas and their needs
and their use cases.
DON DODGE: So you could have
teenage users and middle age
users and women and men, and
they have slightly different
use cases and personas.
So that's the idea?
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah.
There's a whole process to how
not to create conflicting
personas, like you can't please
everybody, so that's
kind of a whole other process.
But yeah, you kind of need to
spend a lot of time early on
in the process really figuring
out who your application is
for so you can deliver delight
to those people.
DON DODGE: So a lot of startups
aren't that focused
and methodical.
They dive right in and start
developing features.
I mean, we're engineers so
we're going to start
developing features, and then
pull the features together and
try to build a demo, and then
give it to a few users and
figure out how they're going
to use it, because they'll
say, I don't know what
the use case is.
So how do you get involved with
a startup who's already
built something, and how do you
sort of put that on hold
and go back and do the user
experience design?
IZABEL IDRIS: Well user testing
is crucial, so if you
were to have a prototype
already, I think it's really
good to test it with different
kinds of users.
But when you do test it with
those users, have them
categorized in some way.
Understand that I'm going to do
a test with teenagers, or
I'm going to test with soccer
moms, or I'm going to do a
test with people that are
foodies and then I'm going to
do a test with people who
are bargain shoppers.
So kind of understand who you're
testing with and then
see maybe who your application
is most
successful with those people.
And then from there, I guess
you could kind of reverse
engineer it and then go
into use cases and
personas from there.
But ideally, you really want
to have a clear idea of who
your application is for.
And everybody between
developers, designers, and
product managers can reference
these throughout the process.
Everybody we use uses cases
and personas in slightly
different ways to make different
decisions, but I
think even if you start out with
a prototype and you don't
have spec that you might have
started out with, you
definitely need to try and
define who your users are and
their use cases.
DON DODGE: So earlier you
mentioned to me a application
for ordering pizza.
And let's say there 850,000
apps in the App Store, and
many of them do the
same thing.
So what's an example of a great
user experience versus a
not so great user experience
where the functionality is
exactly the same?
IZABEL IDRIS: I think that comes
down to your special
sauce, no pun intended since
we're talking about pizza.
So your special sauce is really
a way that you can take
your goals and actually turn
those into features to really
meld those two together and
elicit an emotional response
in your users.
So that means it's something
you can engineer.
So for example, let's say you
have a pizza application, and
this pizza application services
users who are foodies
and they're really interested in
getting pizza that's local,
sustainable, and that
they want to give
back to local farms.
So let's say that's my goal
as a pizza company.
In my application when I choose
toppings for my pizza,
they could have a sustainability
score.
And then when I order my pizza,
I could share it on
Google+ and say, look I have
this certain sustainability
score, and try and get your
friends to see if they can
beat your source, so you can
actually gamify the whole
experience.
And then the pizza company could
offer a free pizza to
the person who shared their
pizza if someone else were to
purchase as a result
of their share.
So basically--
and also the users would feel
really good that they've
actually ordered your pizza,
because you're giving back to
local farms.
They're doing something good for
their community by using
your product.
Obviously, your pizza
has to be amazing.
That's kind of a given.
So you may have tons of
companies with great pizza and
a really nice checkout flow
and a really nice ordering
flow, but you're pizza company
makes people feel good about
ordering pizza.
They feel like they're doing
something good for the
community, good for
local farmers--
if that's important to them--
and then, of course, it's fun.
DON DODGE: So building in
gamification into the user
experience makes a generic
kind of pizza application
special and unique and
more successful.
IZABEL IDRIS: Exactly.
DON DODGE: Great.
Who knew that user experience
could improve a pizza
application?
Well, thank you very much.
This has been great.
Thank you for joining us, and
join us again when we have
another Root Access
show on issues of
importance to startups.
I have a special offer for
"Google Root Access" viewers.
We're offering a $2,000 credit
on the Google Cloud Platform,
so if you're a developer who
uses a back end in the Cloud,
this is a great opportunity for
you to get started with
Google Cloud Platform and save
$2,000 at the same time.
The instructions are
on the screen.
The link will be in the YouTube
description, so go
there to get started.
Thank you very much for
joining us, and see
you again next time.